Let's go next to our caller from the nine
five six area code.
Who is calling today from nine five six.
Hey, this is Michael from Texas.
Hey Mike.
What's going on?
Um, so I was wondering if you, if you knew
about the specifics of the, of Bernie's through
college plan.
W w uh, well, I mean, I reviewed it when he
first published it.
Is there something in particular about it
you wanted to ask about?
I don't have it in front of me.
Um, yeah.
So, uh, the way it works for the rest of my
knowledge is, um, it's a, it's essentially
a grant to the States, um, from the federal
government where the federal government offers
to pay two thirds of the cost of making tuition
free in the state.
And then the state gets to opt in, um, to,
uh, the free college tuition.
And I'm wondering if, if we will see Republican
States like, um, Texas obviously who, uh,
didn't expand Medicaid under Obama also, uh,
not extend, um, this, uh, three college, um,
snacks.
Absolutely.
So this is, this is, this is how they'll do
it.
So as you're rightly pointing out, we had
Obamacare, Obamacare.
One of the things that it offered was a, an
opt in to for States to expand Medicaid.
And I believe with Obamacare, the federal
government would pay 90%, but the, the detail
is not totally relevant here.
You saw a lot of red state governors, governors
in red States, Republican governors, uh, not
do the optin.
And then the citizens of those States said,
Obamacare passed and nothing improved.
That's because Obamacare is bad.
And of course it's actually because their
governor chose not to opt in.
So here's the way they're going to play it.
If Bernie Bernie's plan for college would
happen, a lot of red States would not opt
in.
Uh, then what they would do is let a couple
of years go by and then they would say, look,
Bernie's free college plan costs us
$500 billion.
And our, uh, college attendance rate has actually
gone down.
And it's like, well, hold on a second.
You didn't participate in the optin and the
reason that your college, uh, rate probably
went down is because people are moving to
other States that did do it in order to go
to school.
And a lot of Republican voters will fall for
that.
And then they'll say, free college is terrible.
And it'll be another one of these non information
cycles that are so common in politics.
Hello.
Oh, um, all right.
Thank you.
Oh, okay.
All right.
That was weird.
Thank you for the call.
That's my best assessment of the situation.
As of right now, l